hey guys it's max and vadim and we just
finished the apple event and they
completely blew us away it's absolutely
insane um today in this video we're
going to give you guys a thought on how
we still can't think properly
all the crazy stuff and also some stuff
that is a bit disappointing we're going
to cover it all yeah so i mean we've
been hyping you guys up over the past
year with these new macbook pros telling
you guys that they're going to be
literally the best laptops sometimes
that's a slow video ever paid
and apple just blew us away like our
expectations were like super high and we
told you guys and we are blown away
because apple did things that even i
wasn't expecting like they went above
and beyond with things like double the
video encoders like who does that it's
promotion that's one thing we didn't
think it happened i thought that was
coming in like a year or two and i was
like yeah you know that kind of sucks
then i'm not getting it but
they gave us promotion and i want to say
the ordering experience was the most
stressful i've ever had anything
ordering new iphone 13s it's always bad
this was worse the app is crashing the
website is crashing orders are switching
the dates are going back
further like right in front of my eyes i
can't process anything the whole website
is crashing so how much did we buy oh
okay so i bought eight macbook pros
eight um we guys if you're not yet
subscribed we bought seriously 14 core a
16 core graphics
24 core graphics a 32 core graphics all
the ram 16 gig 32 gig 64 gig ram 14
inches and 16 inchers we are gonna give
you guys the most comprehensive macbook
pro coverage out of any any answer you
have on ram thermal throttling which
we're gonna talk about in a second
we're gonna have it all guys so make
sure you guys are subscribed and help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
we would greatly appreciate it and now
the moment that i have been dreading for
the past couple of hours
oh come on i know i said it was going to
be m1x
it apple apple switched it up
apple switched it up at the last minute
so
m1 pro not our
max chip come on
yeah so
because of this
we're gonna be doing something special
for you guys max go ahead yep so we are
going to do a promo code for you guys um
m1 pro is going to be the code right now
live right now save 20 persona off of
all of our merchants it's already too
low price i'm telling medivh our merch
is too cheap and i'm making you guys
want to support us go and check it out
and for all of you guys that now want to
get an m1 pro or an m1 pro mac shirt we
are working on that that will be up soon
so check out not only the merch shelf
check out the link that's actually
updated first where you can update your
shirt or maybe buy one like this if you
want it updated and you guys can support
us use that code that's limited time
m1 pro promo code to save on our merch
and we would greatly appreciate it
alright guys and now let's get into our
honest thoughts and opinions both the
good and the bad on these new macbook
pros and we're not going to get into
configurations and which specs you
should buy there's so much changes this
year oh my goodness and you there's
definitely big mistakes that you guys
could make but that is going to be in
tomorrow's video so enable those
notifications
so tomorrow what do you think vadim i
mean that macbook pro is a thick
boy i mean who expected apple to make
them thicker you know we thought they're
going to make them thinner with apple
silicon because it's more efficient and
they could have and that was our first
reaction we see this chunk this fat
thick junk fat macbook pro i mean look
at it what is it like four percent
thicker right yeah it's actually not
that thicker i actually have to get the
calculator out when they're mentioning
the specs i'm like this thing is massive
we're going back to like power book days
but just the design isn't shaped to look
thin anymore apple didn't care apple
just had one gold that they're going for
so my theory was that with this macbook
pro the new macbook pros they are
literally
making everybody happy you know people
complain about the lack of ports they
gave them back hdmi sd card slot they
give you everything they even give you
pro motion they give you performance
they give you the full set of function
keys got rid of the touch bar they give
you maxing they are literally trying to
make everybody happy that's so unlike
apple they're appealing to literally
everyone to grab the biggest chunk of
market share and basically destroy the
laptop market
and basically put all the other windows
laptop manufacturers make them shake in
their boots wondering how they're gonna
compete and they're all gonna be going
arm risk five because that's the only
way they can compete but the thing is at
this point even a year later
the arm chips the other companies don't
even match the m1
that the m1 is smoking 11 gen uh and now
we have this this is a new era for apple
they're just gonna destroy the market
from now on
it's insane and of course you guys know
the notch is real unfortunately we saw
rumors over the weekend and first people
are saying like nah this can't be true
this is crazy but you guys saw the crazy
notch sticking out in that first shot so
i guess i understand they wanted to make
that top bezel a lot thinner they said i
think 67
you know to match the sides it's even
now if you can see that notch now
sometimes when you have full screen they
actually hide the full notch they put a
bar there in that case you don't see it
but i am a little bit disappointed not
in the fact that we have a notch there i
am okay with that but why not put face
id and they even put in promotion which
we didn't think would happen
but face id would have been so nice and
now we have a notch without face id yeah
i guess they're just preparing the
design for the next uh year or two when
face id comes it's there the notch is
there that's put face id if they can
make sense but it sucks we don't have it
now all right so we have that thick boy
but what do we get for that extra
thickness well the first thing that
apple mentioned was that this thing has
50 more airflow than the previous 16
inch and that's even at low speeds now
if you didn't know the 15 inch when we
upgraded to the 16 they said it got 28
more airflow that was a good improvement
this is 50 percent more that's really
gonna help with cooling now there's
another thing about fans we'll leave in
a bit uh but i also want to mention the
extra thickness i guess and the weight
so both models the 14 and the 16 are
about four percent uh thicker than
before so not a big difference but as
far as weight we have a much bigger
difference the 16 inch is nine percent
heavier than before and that's actually
with the lighter version of the 16 inch
um but with the 14 inch that is 17
heavier that's going to be noticeable
compared to a 13-inch macbook pro
um so that's the weight difference right
there in the size of course we got the
updated keyboards what do you think
about the new black keyboard so i like
it because it stands out from basically
every macbook ever made now you have
black surrounding the keys and of course
apple just totally ditched the touch bar
they didn't even care they didn't
apologize no excuses no apology they
just gave us full size function keys
that's it you know they also gave us the
circular touch id button from the magic
keyboard from the imac so you got the
little circle on there and honestly i'm
excited for it i think it's gonna look
good and with all of those crazy new
ports there are a couple
sketchy things and a couple downsides
now of course we didn't expect apple to
ever bring back hdmi
or an sd card reader or mac safe before
they said you just need four usb type-c
ports with thunderbolt that's all you
don't need a sd
you don't need hdmi and now they gave it
to us now with the sd card reader
they're not saying what speed that is i
really hope it's the new type 3 which
goes up to like almost 700 megabytes per
second razer's been using that for two
years now i really hope it's not the
older version that we've had for years
but with the hdmi port i don't know if
you guys noticed but they did not
mention the spec they did not mention
it's hdmi 2.1 and so we looked into it
and what would even found is that it
just literally says 4k 64k
that means no 8k there that means no no
4k 120
and that is a disappointment i don't
know why they didn't set it up that way
hdmi 2.0 that's all you get i guess you
might still need to use that thunderbolt
4
if you want to support those ak displays
and stuff like that yep and speaking of
that we do have thunderbolt 4. it's not
three you know it's not usb4 it's
official thunderbolt 4 and i don't know
if you guys know this or not but the the
m1 macbook pros they actually said usb4
but they supported thunderbolt for uh
adapters and hubs right yep so they
supported the speeds but they couldn't
say official thunderbolt 4 because they
did not support enough displays yep and
now we can go
two or up to four
so which is nice yeah because of that
it's official thunderbolt 4. now i'm
super excited for magsafe and i don't
know if you guys noticed but this new
max a3 is incredibly slim slightly
bigger than usb type c super thin and
what really got me excited is that 50
charge in 30 minutes it's annoying
listening for the waiting for these
macbooks now that you're used to fast
charging with phones so that is amazing
but most likely you will have to use the
magsafe connector um in order to get
that fast speed and with that huge 140
watt it's like power brick it's huge
look at that thing and for your 16 inch
now of course for the smaller one i'm
not sure because that usbc port which
you can still use for charging that
maxes out at 100 watts 100 watts it
might be enough still for the 14 inch i
guess we'll have to see and now getting
into the splay of course we have that
notch which kind of sucks but at least
they made the bezels a lot thinner
especially on the top now in my opinion
the bezels on the 16 inch were already
like okay good enough i wasn't really
expecting not in my opinion but but now
they made it like super thin right so
that's awesome and they give us the
rounded corners on the top so they're
matching with the mac os monterey look
of all the rounded corner windows and
everything so it's gonna look great now
i'm excited for the new displays this is
probably the craziest thing for me and
not only do we have mini led and 1000
it's sustained that's like the this the
6k display i paid six grand for a
thousand is sustained 1600 peak that is
incredible but they raised the
resolution too which i wasn't expecting
almost a 4k display 3.5 k display 4k uhd
is 3.8k
from 2.6 so now it's a 254
ppi yep right there from 218 so they're
making these sharper a lot brighter
better contrast and it's a 10-bit panel
as well so for people doing color
grading photo editing apple was good
before but now with that mini led
display it's going to be absolutely
amazing and apple said this is the
world's best notebook display and i
believe them because with all of that
they're also giving us 120hz promotion
now it's not just a 120hz display you're
getting promotion tech which means that
when you're watching a video at 24 24
fps 24 hertz it goes down and it saves
battery life or 60 fps whatever or when
you're gaming let's say playing league
of legends you're instantly getting 120
fps solid with the crazy graphics
performance and that's going to happen
for a lot of games so this is so
exciting and with that too not only can
it go 120 hertz or down to 24. it can
adjust to what you're gaming at the
refresh rate just like g-sync
that makes it a lot smoother as you guys
you gamers know with that i'm awesome of
course apple had to fix that camera
finally that 720p camera was there for
like five six years and even though the
m1 chip made it look better this thing
this 1080p camera is gonna be a lot
better it has smart hdr now thanks to
the neural engine and the image signal
processor and everything so we're
excited for that i actually use facetime
and do conferencing a lot of times i'd
actually switch to my cell phone because
it looked way better than the macro pro
especially in low light of course you
have the new f 2.0 aperture so that
thing is going to look great and not
only that but they even upgraded the
microphones which was a shocker apple's
crazy the studio mics before were
amazing some of you guys actually
commented and said that it sounded as
good as our 500 uh mic that we record
separately into a 350 live recorder and
processed audio the mac was sounded good
now it has less noise 60 lower noise
floor yeah than the last one yeah and of
course the speakers too so as you guys
know the previous 16 inch macbook pro
basically had the best speakers of any
laptop ever like amazing sounding
speakers and apple made them better they
doubled the size of the tweeters they
give us the force canceling woofers with
80
more bass like the bass was already
crazy and they improved it i'm excited
here man they even put that six speaker
system into the 14-inch apple and one
thing that totally blew my mind was the
ssd speed apple said it's 7.4 gigabytes
per second now i personally i was hoping
for maybe five but they give us 7.4
that's basically over double the speed
and this is gonna matter so much for ssd
caching because even if you don't get
like a lot of unified memory it's going
to be able to use the ssd caching to
speed up the system and when it happens
twice as fast at 7.4 gigabytes per
second that's just going to help so much
yeah so if you don't get the 32 gig or
64 gig that's going to help yeah it's
going to help a lot now i want to talk
about battery life this is one area
where we were a little bit disappointed
we thought we did the calculations based
on the efficiency and everything that
this thing's going to have at least 30
hours of battery life 25 apple set 21
which is the best battery life on any
laptop at least real world battery life
rating one hour better than the 13 inch
macbook pro
but there's a couple things that we
haven't considered so the first thing is
you have the pro motion display a lot of
times you're running at 120 hertz two
it's a lot brighter than before uh a
thousand knits sustained
if you have hdr cons up to 600 that uses
a lot more power
instead of 2.6 exactly it's going to go
inside a 2.6 k we're up to 3.5 k almost
4k resolution um on the 16 inch that
also uses more battery they couldn't
make the battery any bigger actually
if they went from 99.5 up to 100 watt
hours which is the absolute limit to be
allowed in an airplane you literally
can't get any bigger than that
um but the reason why the battery life
isn't as good as what i mentioned and
the fact that they were not trying to
focus on energy efficiency they got rid
of two of the efficiency cores and went
from four efficiency cores down to two
they're trying to maximize the cpu
performance maximize the graphics
performance and i think that we'll get
into this in a bit but they mentioned
that 60 watts i think with the graphics
the 32 core yeah they've never had a
laptop that had went over 50. 50 was the
cap so they're just carrying more we're
going all out about performance
now i was a bit bummed when they
actually mentioned how much longer you
can do for example lightroom editing
they said that you could do it for twice
as long like twice as long i thought i'd
be like three or four times longer like
on the m1 macbook pros but what they
didn't factor in or i didn't think about
is
it's gonna do that like four or five
times faster yeah so you don't have to
be you're not gonna be waiting that long
it's gonna happen so quick
that
you just that helps a lot and of course
we have the 50 fast charging as well and
now with all that said let's finally get
into the chips all the performance m1
pro
m1 max so with that said apple did say
that the new chip the 10 core is up to
70 faster than the m1 that's a little
bit disappointing because i was
expecting more and just making that
calculation out it becomes kind of like
13 000 geekbench 5 multi-core score
compared to my prediction of about
fourteen thousand and a half to fifteen
so i wonder why a little bit
disappointment there i'm not really sure
i think it's thermals do you think they
just wanna save thermal for the graphics
yeah maybe they're just focusing more on
graphics i will say my mac pro
with with uh 12 cores that run uses 180
watts that gets 12 500. yeah it beefs so
this macbook even the 14 inch will beat
my mac pro there you go on battery power
it's still good and of course we have
the graphics 16 core on the 14 inch and
interestingly you do actually get a bend
version with the base model it's a 14
core gpu so you're not getting quite as
much but maybe it's not going to be that
big of a difference because the 16 core
we will test it we will test it it does
have 5.2 teraflops of performance which
is very very interesting but i think the
big deal is the accelerators in the
codex yeah this is something that's
groundbreaking um of course in my mac
pro i paid i think was it two thousand
or 2500 for this
card
to decode prores and this machine even
the 16 core and even the 14 core
graphics it not only can decode pro res
it can encode progress with which the
mac pros afterburner cannot do nothing
else other than a new iphone
there's no laptop there's no desktop
that can encode prores to make that
faster and then with that the pro max or
just the m1 max chip and one max that
actually has dual encoders and decoders
for the regular codecs nobody's ever
done this before and usually limitation
like in my mac pro i have a crazy
graphics card more powerful than what in
these machines but you're still limited
by your encoders no matter how many
graphics cards you have four in there
you're still not getting any faster
encoders because that's the limitation
here they doubled it which is going to
make renders insane twice as fast um
twice as fast compared to not having the
dual yeah four five eight times faster
than before i can't wait to put this
thing up against my mac pro oh man it's
gonna smoke video editing is insane and
now speaking of that higher end m1 max
chip it actually requires you to have 32
gigs of unified memory because that's
kind of the way it's just built but the
crazy thing is you can get up to 400
gigabytes per second memory bandwidth
now comparing that to the console
playstation 5 that one gets 448 so
you're almost getting a full ps5 in a
laptop but to blow your mind even more
that graphics ship the 32 core has 10.4
teraflops of performance the ps5 has
10.28
and that's with the plugged in right
that's what they plugged in that's what
it plugged in this mac but what apple
said is you get that performance
unplugged so they said that they found
the most powerful laptop graphics card
they put it against this thing of course
that one was more powerful i don't know
by how much i know one gets 15 teraflops
that uses 160 watts of power apples
either uses 55 or 60. i think they said
100
watts less 100 and then if you match up
the same wattage then apples gets two
and a half times the performance that's
how much the efficiency is but not only
that if you unplug that high-end laptop
that uses 160 watts just for graphics
we've done this many times the
performance goes insanely lower and
we've seen where like another laptop be
neck and neck with an apple laptop then
you unplug it and it's like three times
slower with this one it says it's three
and a half times faster
if they're unplugged this mac laptop is
and with the laptop you don't always
want to be plugged in you want to be
able to move and use it which is the
really cool thing yeah and it's crazy
with that unified memory you can get up
to 64 gigs but the thing that people
aren't realizing is that can be used as
the ram i didn't realize 64 gigs v ram
people usually complain about people
should complain yeah you have to share
the system memory you're limited and i
think a lot of integrated ones actually
have caps on there not this unified
memory and i didn't even realize until
video mentioned this like my mac pro has
32 gigabytes of video memory and even if
you stack for those graphics cards
you're still limited to 32 because it
has to be duplicated for sli the way
this works is it doesn't have to be
duplicated you're not wasting memory and
you literally you're gonna have 30 64
gigs of video memory if the app needs it
which we've never seen before and on top
of that the actual gpu has dedicated
tile memory and its own caches on top of
the vram all right so obviously we're
fanboying like crazy i'm guessing you
guys probably are too even people that
aren't macbook fans they will be they're
yes they will be
what are the downsides and what are the
other
issues i guess well the first thing that
i teased earlier we saw that on the
16-inch model under the weight it
actually mentioned a higher weight for
the m1 max chip uh i think it was like a
tenth of a pound heavier yeah and then
that's not enough for a little extra
little chiplet that's brought down so
i'm guessing that they might be actually
having better fans for the 16-inch m1
max chip because on the 14-inch they
don't say that at all they don't say
yeah there's a version that's heavier if
you get the max chip so that means that
we could have thermal throttling with
the 14-inch compared to the 16-inch um
or maybe you might want to get those
fans so we're going to test that out and
then of course
apple gave us everything
and they gave us some prices yeah some
big prices so we were thinking
there's a chance that apple could leave
this at eighteen hundred dollars that's
before we thought we didn't think
promotion was gonna come no but we
thought eighteen hundred bucks and they
could bin it yeah or maybe they'll just
up the price to two grand it's a lot of
money bring it back to it used to be two
grand years ago
bring it up to two grand again and then
give us the full m1 x chip unbids
but what do they do
well they basically raise the price to
2000 and they bend it twice they double
banded you got an eight core cpu and you
have a 14 core gpu band twice and if you
want an unbind m1 pro chip you're paying
2 300
200 bucks more if you want to get a 10
quarter and then another 100 or 300
bucks more 2300 if you want to get the
same chip that's in the 16 inch which
means there's only 200 price difference
between the 14 and 16 inch in the same
configuration
before um they had like a 600 price
difference between of course there were
other differences and stuff but now it's
almost like you get to just choose do
you just want to save a little money for
a smaller size or whatever yeah and i
mean that 16 inch the value on the 16
inch is really good you're getting the
unbin chip for that price only 200 more
than the 14 inches yeah that's pretty of
course we're going to get into this
there's a couple different traps some
other traps in there there's charger
differences there's other things that
video will be coming out tomorrow so
make sure you guys click that subscribe
button above if you haven't yet help us
reach a million subscribers we would
greatly appreciate it check out one of
those videos there use the promo code uh
m1 m1 pro to check out some merch make
sure you guys check when we update it
this has been max and vadim and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]